the Joe Rogan experience yeah my tyson
we were talking when you went to the
bathroom Mike Tyson says he smokes
$40,000 oh yeah we also sells weed so he
just charges himself a lot of money
forty thousand dollars worth of weed
they may be like his whole crew yeah
this ain't about himself there's no way
a month
yeah just 40,000 I want to see what it
looks like in a room yes I am at it
would be a pile that you could fall into
and thinkin that but you could be like
beanbag chair and you can fly with
confidence so how much is I'm you're
getting in bulk so it's gonna be
probably like a hundred dollars it's
getting worse and even less than that
but you're gonna spend 40 grand they'll
give you more than 40 grands worth do
you I used to be like here we smoked 10
tons of weed at the ranch a month oh my
god this is britain said eben is that is
a high say same even Evan Evan Britain
so 10 tons of weed is forty thousand
dollars that doesn't seem right
doesn't none of that seems twenty
thousand pounds of weed that's
impossible
he obviously could have easily been
joking and laughing why said this to
we're reading it in print yeah he's like
do we smoke 10 tons a month yeah this is
sounds like something I would say more
than ever possibly imagine I'm gonna
throw out a wild number forty million
forty thousand there's someone she made
them some journalist should do like do
just make an image of this is what forty
thousand dollars where the weed looks
like yeah it's gonna be more than with
even less Tyson and his crew can smoke
wouldn't fill this whole room I think it
would be like shipping crates is a grab
is it even possible to smoke forty
thousand dollars a weed a month nine
hundred eighty not that much but with a
crew and I know I think about it if you
do
two grand blunts that's two blunts per
eighth essentially a little bit less
this guy's got a broken down baby this
guy really could just tell you how much
it is in bulk he's giving you the 908
seems a little bit lazy to even write
1,800 blunts between Mike Tyson's crew
is not actually that much for a month
it's not that much now I'm looking at
how this guy saying it he's saying it's
basically four blunts per hour that's
totally possible if you got a large
number of people with you I will never
question Mike Tyson again ever this is
about ten tons I think we're being silly
I think they were joking around I bet a
lot of it they give away too
you know they might go through a
personal stash of that much weed I don't
know he has a ranch
all right Tyson's in the weed game son
all-in dude he was one of the most
fascinating guys at interview because I
couldn't believe I was really talking to
him yeah so I can't believe that's
really Mike Tyson like there's some
people like you talk to my god that's
really Mike Tyson doesn't make sense
what he's been through in his life yet
now he's here somehow knowing him as a
kid when he was the [ __ ] man and
you'd see him on the cover of these
magazines like Kid Dynamite when he's 19
years old on Sports Illustrated and just
smashing everyone in front of him and
then all sudden he's hanging with you
yeah it's very strange it's also just as
a fall from grace and then a resurgence
and still weird resurgence to like
nobody ever saw him becoming like you
know cartoon character and like a
[ __ ] Broadway actor and a one-man
show and now a weed rancher who saw that
nobody said that was gonna be Mike Tyson
show director yeah I just rode the tech
the the trajectory of when I found out
who he was when I was a kid and started
getting it was BOTS like very shortly
after you saw what a monster he was was
that Robin Givens interview where he
just sat there like a doofus
yeah well she was like eh beats up me
and rapes my mom and he's like when
these cameras go off oh boy wasn't there
some talk about them medicating him
wasn't that part of what was happening
like they were the mama
forgive him to date him maybe I just
remember him talking about sorry yeah
and the documentary and he was just like
he said he was just so he couldn't
believe she was saying it so he was just
like silent but if you watch it it seems
like he's furious hmm and just trying to
not say something angry he to Mike Tyson
is that he always seemed like he was
furious
yeah oh and he even talked about it once
it goes I'm just mad I'm mad at my dog
I'm mad at everything and that's when he
was at the top of the heap but for how
he's like this peaceful friendly God he
had to overcompensate for all that
that's what he needs 40,000 Gerald it
was all therapy right he had to be in he
had like 20 therapists he beat up the
first seven of them I mean Judy a great
fighter you have to be able to look at
yourself you have to be able to look at
your skills you still doesn't mean you
still can't make horrific mistakes but
you have to be able to look at yourself
it's only you get any better the best
fighters have an understanding even if
they have ego problems they still have a
pretty good understanding of who they
are and that's that can benefit you if
you use it today I'm sure he probably
went through therapy but he didn't
necessarily he could probably have
figured it out on his own just cuz he's
a smart guy he's a smart guy they grew
up in a horrible horrible way where the
first love he had was an old boxing
trainer that turned him into a murderer
that was the first love that guy
experienced his life was horrible man
and from him being adopted by custom
Honor when he was a little kid and
having extreme physical gifts as well it
was this perfect storm dude they said
when he was 13 he weighed a hundred and
ninety pounds Teddy Atlas used to bring
him to boxing the smoker events and they
were like yeah he's [ __ ] 13 and they
put him in with a 16 year old does
nobody want to believe that a 13 year
old could be jacked like that well g1j
with when J 3rd was 13 years old he
weigh like 220 it's true was it
different built I was knocking
[ __ ] out god damn tank yeah
that's not a thirteen-year-old you want
to fight how also fun fact he is the
reason Mike Tyson solely is the reason
why now if you're on TV for even 5
minutes they starts caring about your
tattoos being covered or can you get a
release for them all because when he
came on a
was it hangover movie the company that
did were the tattoo artists that did its
face tattoo sued for like I think one
for like millions of dollars that's so
possible for doing they use that
person's artwork without then once you
put a tattoo once nobody is your own no
heart yeah you claim part ownership of
that yes it makes tattoo so much gayer